what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime out Pro and today I will be
talking about a new anime that began
airing in the summer 2019 season and an
anime that a lot of people have been
talking about as someone who hasn't read
the manga I came into the doctor stone
anime with a completely blank slate and
although some people that I know and
respect have praised the manga in the
past I honestly had no idea what to
expect
I thought the first episode was
interesting enough but it didn't exactly
dazzle me it set up an intriguing world
but for all I knew at the time the
entire rest of the series could have
just been sanku and tied to going full
bear grylls man vs. wild for like a
dozen episodes however as soon as I saw
episode 2 and especially the ending of
episode 2 I was hooked some of the best
anime that I've seen including Death
Note Code Geass and Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood really managed to impress me
and hook me on that second episode this
is because these anime used the first
episode to introduce us to the world and
the characters and then write an episode
2 they introduced a fundamental and
compelling conflict that keeps us coming
back for more
with that said there will be some
spoilers in this video up to the end of
episode 2 of the dr. stone anime but
nothing beyond that in the case of dr.
stone the primary conflict introduced in
episode 2 is a fundamental clash of
ideas it is a radical conflict of
philosophies between sanku the genius
scientist and pragmatist and Tsukasa the
physically overpowered radical idealist
this conflict doesn't only set up a
rivalry between two characters it sets
up a rivalry between two completely
different philosophies and outlooks on
life and in the unique setting of the
stone world this philosophical rivalry
becomes the driving force of the entire
plot at least at these early stages of
the story
after spending 3700 years in a petrified
state that appears to be some form of
cryostasis childhood friends sanku and
tide you'll wake up to find that they
are seemingly the only living humans in
a world that has been completely
reclaimed by Nature
all other people are seemingly still
petrified city's modern technology and
society as a whole have completely
disappeared and all around them sank
tied you find themselves in a world that
has been thrust all the way back to the
Stone Age this is a pretty daunting
situation to find yourself in but sanku
does not despair he puts his genius
science skills to work in order to
figure out how to deep petrified the
other humans and bring back modern
society as quickly as possible
Zankou says that humanity spent two
million years getting from the Stone Age
to the modern age but Zankou wants to
speed up that process
sanku believes that science can explain
everything including the mysterious and
outright fantastical mass petrification
phenomenon but he acknowledges that
science is a slow process that requires
a lot of experimentation a lot of trial
and error as sanku says science is just
a name for the pain-in-the-ass process
of looking at the root causes of
everything and how it all comes together
and despite the fantastical nature of
the mass petrification sanku boldly
proclaims I am going to beat fantasy
with science
although sang coos friend ty Chu is
primarily driven by the desire to rescue
usury huh the girl that he has been in
love with for years
sanku and Ty do generally seem to be on
the same page when it comes to their
desire to rescue as many people as
possible and bring back modern society
to the greatest possible extent however
major complications arise right in
episode 2 using the incredible power of
science and bad waste sanku figures out
a formula that allows him to depetro fie
the other humans
sanku and tide you have only a limited
amount of the substance at first and
they decide to use it to D petrify usury
huh but after they are attacked by lions
in the wilderness Lions who are
seemingly descendents of the Lions who
escaped Japanese zoos after the mass
petrification sanku and tied you are
forced to depend else first the
strongest fighter in their former high
school Tsukasa as insanely overpowered
as sanku is intellectually Tsukasa is
equally overpowered physically and he is
able to take down and kill a lion with a
single punch at first everything seems
to be going well between the three
carrot
sukkah sighs extremely grateful to sanku
and tied you for rescuing him from his
stone state and in return he promises to
hunt for them and protect them while
sanku uses his scientific genius to help
them establish a functional mini society
however by the end of episode two the
honeymoon is already over as suka sansan
qu realized that they have completely
different and inherently opposing goals
for their new society sank whose
decision to try to bring back modern
society and save everyone he possibly
can make sense to us at first glance but
it is important to understand that this
is not a politically neutral decision
sank who is making several assumptions
when he decides to do his best to bring
back society to where it was before the
petrification he is assuming that modern
society was something positive something
just and something that should be
emulated once again in the stone world
in this sense sank whose philosophy
could be described as conservative now I
don't mean conservative in the sense of
any specific political party or
political agenda but rather in the way
that a political philosopher like Edmund
Burke might understand conservatism
sanku is assuming that modern society as
it was before the petrification was a
good thing that there is a reason why
society evolved the way it did in the
first place and that the best course of
action is to model this new society on
the old one on the other hand su casa
has a very different view of the stone
world su casa believes that modern
society as it was before the
petrification was unjust and corrupt in
many ways su casa doesn't want to bring
back society to the way it was he wants
to change it for the better
su casa says were free in this stone
world shells never belonged to anyone
the same goes for the sea and the land
su casa believes that if they tried to
bring back everyone and restore society
to the way it was this would lead to
conflict over property and money and
eventually this would result in war and
suffering su casa wants to avoid this by
starting a new su casa believes that the
only way to start fresh is to take a
very radical step he wants to bring back
to life only the young the children and
the youth
and he wants to get rid of all the
adults by the way when someone's body is
broken while they are in there petrified
state they die for real and they cannot
be revived again if natal H or natal H
I'm not sure how to pronounce that but
it's the substance that D petrifies
people is poured on people who have been
smashed in their stone form these people
will simply become corpses they are
already dead and this is exactly what
Tsukasa begins doing
he begins smashing the petrified adults
that he comes across and he doesn't make
a distinction between adults who are bad
people and adults who may be good people
and who may be completely innocent of
any wrongdoing
Tsukasa simply begins to kill the adults
indiscriminately as soon as sanku
witnesses took us as immense strength he
immediately understands how dangerous
Tsukasa is in a world with no organized
society those who are physically
strongest get to decide everything it
might makes right if you are weaker you
are at the mercy of the stronger and
this is the exact situation that sank
who and tied you find themselves in
Senko and tied you do not approve of
tsukasa's philosophy and his decision to
kill the adults but they cannot stop him
physically Nautilus sank who can use his
scientific genius to create weapons that
will be capable of overpowering Tsukasa
that is exactly what sank who sets out
to do and the conflict between these two
drastically different philosophies
begins while I obviously disagree with
tsukasa's actions because he takes it
upon himself to kill all the adults
whether they are good people or bad
people his philosophy is indeed very
interesting and it is deeply rooted in
the political philosophy of our own non
stone world a couple of years ago I
wrote and successfully defended a PhD
dissertation that focused primarily on
jean-jacques Rousseau one of my favorite
philosophers and someone whose critique
of modern society has many parallels to
the ideas put forth by Tsukasa in his
famous work called the discourse on the
origins of inequality among men Rousseau
argues that man is by nature good
innocent and compassionate Rousseau says
that before organized society was
established back in a time when all
human beings basically just lived off
the land like nomads there was no war or
suffering
every human being took only what they
needed to survive and they never had any
reason to take more than they needed or
to steal from others in this state of
nature before the rise of organized
society human beings were unequal in
terms of natural things like physical
strength and intelligence but they were
not unequal in terms of wealth or social
privilege because those things did not
exist Rousseau imagined the natural man
as something akin to an animal if two
hungry squirrels climb up the same tree
and go for the same nut only one will
come away with the nut in the end but
the other squirrel will not get mad or
hold a grudge against the squirrel that
took the nut the squirrel that didn't
get the nut will not go back to its
squirrel friends and organize a posse in
order to start a war against the other
squirrel the squirrel that didn't get
the nut will simply move on and look for
another nut and the so called conflict
will end there Rousseau imagined natural
humans to be similar to this they took
only what they needed to survive they
had no reason to take more than they
needed especially since if they tried to
take too much it would just spoil anyway
and so there would never be any reason
for humans to hold grudges against each
other much less to go to war against
each other nevertheless as soon as human
beings started living in organized
society everything changed instead of
living free and independent lives humans
started depending on each other and
competing with each other they created
private property they created money they
created social status and rank and they
began competing with each other for
these things they started taking more
than they needed even if that meant that
other people would have way less than
they needed for bear survival and this
was the origin of all inequality and
corruption in modern society Rousseau
says the following the first man who
having enclosed a piece of ground
bethought himself of saying this is
mined and found people simple enough to
believe him was the real founder of
civil society from how many crimes wars
and murders from how many horrors and
misfortunes might not anyone have saved
mankind by pulling up the stakes or
filling up the ditch and crying to his
fellows beware of listening to this
impostor you were undone if you once
forget that the fruits of the earth
belong to us all and the
earth itself to nobody so according to
Rousseau the first person who created
private property instead of behaving as
if the entire earth belonged to everyone
equally was the true founder of civil
society and this is what eventually
leads to all of the unfairness and
inequality in the world now compare what
was so said to tsukasa's words when
talking to sanku about sank whose plan
to bring back everyone including the
adults Tsukasa says the following
they'll be grateful to you at first but
as soon as civilization returns the rich
and powerful seniors will say that used
to be my land pay your rent pay your
taxes they'll rob the poor youth of our
future again we must not bring that
world back this is a stone world an
untainted paradise will revive only the
pure hearted youth and live in a natural
world owned by no one it's a chance to
purify humanity essentially Tsukasa
wants to bring back Russo's natural man
the innocent and primitive man who
existed before the creation of modern
society sank who obviously disagrees as
he is a technology loving boy who gets
excited over Mex and space and stuff
like that he vows to use the power of
science to rescue every single person
this sets up a fascinating philosophical
dichotomy and of course I was hooked as
soon as I saw all of this take shape at
the end of episode 2 but let's dig a bit
deeper
the thing about Russo is that he fully
acknowledged that his natural man who
was free innocent and uncorrupted by
modern society probably never actually
existed or if he did exist there is no
way to prove it
Russo's idea of the state of nature is a
thought experiment he uses this concept
of the state of nature and natural man
to prove that modern society as it is
right now is inherently unfair and
corrupt but he states clearly and
directly that humanity cannot go back to
the natural state we cannot return to a
point in history where society does not
exist because of this Rousseau wants us
to do our best to make our current
society more just and more free Rousseau
does not advocate for the abolishing of
private property and he does not claim
that human beings need to go back to
living like no
math instead he says that even though
living in an organized society has many
challenges it also gives us many new
opportunities that we couldn't have even
dreamed of in a more primitive state and
soul Rousseau goes on to advocate for
things like direct democracy and a
common sense of national identity as
ways of creating a more just society
where people live together but also help
each other and treat each other fairly
Russo's ideas were extremely influential
in the 18th century and they had a
massive impact on the French Revolution
and other historical movements that
wanted to do away with absolutism and
establish a more democratic system of
government but unlike Rousseau other
political thinkers who came after him
did advocate for the abolishing of
private property and the complete
overthrow of the current economic system
this includes Karl Marx Friedrich Engels
and other thinkers that we have come to
associate with the ideology of communism
people like Marx argued that we could
not create a more fair and just society
unless the existing economic structure
was done away with completely and this
includes abolishing private property as
we know it without getting too much into
Marx's historical materialism it is
sufficient to say that Marx believed in
the concept of class struggle the idea
that there are two main classes of
people in modern capitalist societies
the poor majority known as the
proletariat and the rich minority known
as the bourgeoisie according to Marx the
rich minority is exploiting the poor
majority and these poor workers have
become alienated from the products that
they produce from the act of production
itself from other workers and even from
their very essence as human beings
eventually the poor majority will rise
up overthrow the wealthy bourgeoisie and
all private property will be replaced
with communal property this will lead to
true equality and eventually class
distinctions and even national
boundaries will wither away as people
learn to live together in communal
harmony after Marx's death communist
revolutionaries like Vladimir Lenin in
Russia took inspiration from Marx but
they also modified his philosophy to fit
their own needs and circumstances they
sought to put Marx's ideas about
overthrowing the bourgeoisie into
practice and in the pursuit of this goal
they were willing to do rat
things and this includes killing many
innocent people who just happened to
have been born into the upper echelon of
society or who happen to oppose the
ideology of Lenin and the Bolsheviks the
Bolsheviks were willing to kill innocent
people in the name of what they
considered to be a greater goal what
they saw as the greater good of
establishing a classless communist
Society and look no further than the
fate of the Romanov children if you want
to know just how far these communist
revolutionaries were willing to go
tsukasa shares some clear parallels with
this type of revolutionary radicalism
like Rousseau tsukasa believes that
society corrupts human beings and
because they lived in this corrupt
society for a longer period of time
adults are more corrupt than the youth
for this reason in order to create a
more just and fair society tsukasa
believes that we need to start anew and
we must start with the youth who have
not yet been fully corrupted by the
evils of modern society Rousseau never
believed that this type of return to a
more pure existence was possible and he
did not advocate for it but Tsukasa
seized the stone world as the perfect
opportunity to do just that
furthermore like the radical
revolutionaries of the past
Tsukasa is willing to commit radical
acts of violence in the name of his
cause Tsukasa
is willing to end the lives of millions
of adults regardless of whether or not
they are good people because he believes
that the greater good of establishing a
more pure and just society justifies
this sacrifice sanku disagrees of course
and the battle between sanku scientific
genius and tsukasa's physical prowess
also becomes a battle between sank whose
pragmatic conservatism and tsukasa's
revolutionary radicalism I find this
conflict to be absolutely fascinating
and even though I side with sanku and I
can't possibly support Lucas's actions I
am intrigued by tsukasa's philosophy the
petrification that lasted 3,700 years
completely changed the world and these
radically different circumstances
inspired Tsukasa to embrace radical
action in order to create what he
believes to be a new and better world we
can all agree that modern society has
too much corruption and injustice so we
can see where Tsukasa is coming from
even if we reject his methods just like
we can agree with Light Yagami that the
world has to
crime and evil even if we don't support
his mass-murdering methods and this is
precisely what makes for a great anime
conflict even if you reject the villains
methods you can still understand that
perhaps even relate to some of the
villains motivations this type of
conflict makes you think it makes you
re-evaluate your own positions and it
makes you wonder what you would do if
you suddenly found yourself in such a
radically different situation and I love
that in an anime I really enjoy anime
series that put so much thought into
their conflicts and these are the types
of stories that really stick with me
whether it's Psychopaths Code Geass
Death Note Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood or dr. stone I love an anime
that makes me think about politics
philosophy and the pros and cons of
modern society dr. stone really is
deeper than it appears at first glance
and I can't wait to learn more about
this stone world and the apocalyptic
philosophy that lies just beneath the
Shonan surface if you enjoyed this video
you want to see more videos like this
one you can leave a like to let me know
and if you're new to anime uproar please
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell I want to give a huge
thank you to all of our anime upper
patrons for supporting our work and
making our work possible a special thank
you to all of our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson Kings
eldress and on hell crews another
massive thank you to our the one tier
patrons the ones who stand above all
other clans including baby ray ace
ingrid ah al Olin Adam Maddy Mac
makoto-kun
and keelon and finally at the very
pinnacle of interdimensional greatness a
tier reserved only for legends a massive
thank you to Reagan Harrison and Lord
naksan or disciples Oh Lord to ego
himself if you feel that our content
provides value for you when you want to
support more be sure to check out our
patreon link in the description even a
single dollar will give you access to
our patron exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these amazing people as always
thank you guys so much for watching
and until next time see our space
cowboys
[Music]